et
j'ai intégré la sucrerie de bois rouge
en début 2007 et je suis en charge au
sein de la sucrerie comme sur eux cannes
au port notre centre de conditionnement
de sucre de la partie sécurité et
environnement
le groupe tereos océan indien à l'île de
la réunion comprend deux sucreries la
sucrerie de bois rouge à saint-andré et
la sucrerie du gol à saint louis
pendant la campagne mais mission
consiste à garantir que le personnel
travaille en toute sécurité donc nous
sommes en phase de production il y à des
produits chauds il y à un environnement
de travail qui est modifié donc de
garantir que les procédures
d'intervention se passe correctement
durant l'intercampagne
la mission
et principalement pour la partie
sécurité de remettre à jour les
formations et l'autre partie de mon
travail qui est l'environnement donc
c'est
préparer là
la campagne donc s'assurer que le
matériel soit vérifiée est prêt à
démarrer pour la pour la campagne
le projet dont je suis fier c'est la
station d'épuration c'est là où on se
trouve donc c'est un projet qui a pris
deux ans d'études et sur deux ans de
construction qui va nous permettre à la
sucrerie de garantir que l'eau que l'on
rejette soit acceptable pour le milieu
environnant
ce qui me plaît dans mon métier c'est
d'être en contact des personnes sur la
partie sécurité la sécurité ça ne se
fait pas dans un bureau chez ce que je
répète tout le temps c'est la sphère de
tous et sur l'environnement c'est la
même chose c'est au quotidien avec
chaque opérateur avec chaque responsable
qu'est ce que je fais dans mon métier
qui va impacter l'environnement et
qu'est ce que je peux réduire qu'est ce
que je peux améliorer pour que nos
paramètres soient meilleurs